sept heures 18 heures martine première
en voici cinq à dix avec maurice
gueuleton bonjour yan monplaisir vice
présidents d'assemblée de martinique et
désormais candidat dans la
circonscription du nord sous vos
couleurs de la droite merci d'être avec
nous également plaisir pour nous dire
que vous êtes un homme serait apaisée
même pas peur pour tout ce qui se passe
autour de françois fillon candidat de
votre camp pour la présidentielle sera
apaisé car vous auriez pris la bonne
décision celle d'al à la députation et
tant pis pour l'assemblée de martinique
ça veut dire quoi ça c'est tant pis pour
l'assemblée de la martinique il y a eu
des présidents de collectivités qui ont
été sénateur député ça n'a jamais posé
de problème je suis membre de
l'assemblée n'ont pas de l'exécutif et
ça semblait ça semble poser des
interrogations non je suis vous avez
raison je suis serein parce que ma
motivation répond tout simplement à ce
que je crois être une attente de la
population martiniquaise que j'ai
entendu et puis je pense que aujourd'hui
je suis vraiment prêt vraiment prêt j'ai
l'expérience j'ai l'énergie qu'il faut
et donc je suis prêt à servir mon pays
de manière efficace ce n'est pas la
première élection à laquelle vous
présentait il ya le plaisir vous avez
toujours dit être prêt à sortir l'appel
de la population pas de cette manière
générale non j'en crois ce serait
diffusé de fausses images
j'exprimais dans les autres élections
j'exprimais ma détermination et ma
volonté mais cette fois ci il ya un
appel vraiment de la population je le
dis sans forfanterie centaines d'appels
de la population qui regarde ce qui se
passe à droite avec affaires filion je
le dis sans forfanterie avec avec
beaucoup d'humilité parce que j'ai été
sur le terrain c'est pour ça que j'ai
pris le temps de d'indiquer que quelle
était ma décision et de prendre ma
décision
alors il ya de montplaisir vous êtes un
bâtisseur souvient que vous avez quand
même été le des artisans de cette
alliance du grand ensemble et pumba
payant chanceux bâtisseurs est aussi un
des tricoteurs quand vous prenez un
risque de tout casser pas mal des
membres de cette alliance se vend la
députation
est ce que quelque part ça n'envoie pas
signal
peut-être pas dans le sens que vous
vouliez auprès de cette population aux
autres à l'italie l'autre côté un pas du
tout je pense je pense que cette
élection est importante et que il faut
qu'il y ait des candidats qui représente
des sensibilités politiques différentes
et que ses candidats soient des
candidats susceptibles de gagner
oui mais vous avez déjà un job vous avez
déjà un job à la salle et de martinique
a beaucoup travaillent à ses passes et
sexy pour vous écoutez je serai en
mesure de mener les deux de front
d'autres ont fait plus que cela je vous
rappelle que je ne suis pas l'exécutif
je n'aurais donc aucune difficulté à
assumer mes missions d'ailleurs c'est
une marque de fabrique
je suis quelqu'un d'honnête quand je me
présente je me donne les moyens de
rendre compte aux électeurs c'est la
raison pour laquelle je n'ai déjà
indique t indiqué je me suis organisé
pour ne plus avoir de responsabilités
dans le cadre professionnel et donc je
serai plus disponible
parce que est plus disponible est
également plus libre oui mais vous avez
interdit bruno nestor azérot qu'ici même
dans ce studio vous disais pour écouter
yan monplaisir ya déjà beaucoup de
travail à faire et à la semaine
martinique
oui je peux à peine de la députation
nécessaire pour d'autres oui oui je sais
laissez ça pour d'autres jeunes je ne
mesure pas s'ils voulaient ma motivation
à les assumer des responsabilités a fait
d'avoir quelque chose si vous voulez
pour moi c'est pas pour moi que le savoy
quand je vais lâcher permettez je vais
pour la martinique
et donc je trouve que les donneurs de
leçons c'est vous savez c'est un peu
quand haïti caddie qui caddie faut donc
faux dhombres danois parce que quand on
a été pendant de si longues années à la
fois député et maire je crois qu'on n'a
pas de leçon à donner aux autres est en
tout cas je n'ai pas de leçon à recevoir
sur ce chapitre là je suis quelqu'un qui
a l'habitude vous savez ce qui me
différencie de certain nombre d'hommes
politiques c'est que moi j'ai l'habitude
d'assumer les responsabilités et
d'assumer les conséquences des
responsabilités et si je prends
aujourd'hui la raison connaissances et
sa jumelle n'ai pas parlé de bruno
nestor azérot si si je prends la
responsabilité aujourd'hui d'être
candidat c'est que je sais que j'assume
oulémas mission comme je le fais chaque
fois qu'on me confie une mission et
l'idée que les politiques sont tous des
cumulards obsédé par le poste par poste
postes supplémentaires par rapport à ce
qu'ils ont déjà
ça peut être vrai ça peut être vrai pour
ceux qui conçoivent la politique comme
moyen de promotion sociale ou un moyen
de se faire des revenus ce n'est pas mon
cas pour gagner la recette face à bruno
des soeurs à 0 des autres candidats ce
sera d'abord le choix de la suppliante
gt c'est une c'est une des composantes
mais ce qui était impensable déjà arrêté
votre bruit j'ai arrêté mon choix
alors dit tout haut ce batteur je vous
le dirai demain parce qu'il ya encore
des tractations il n'y a aucune
tractation
je souhaiterais en discuter de manière
plus précise et j'ai un rendez vous cet
après midi avec ma suppléante convenir
avec elle de certain nombre de choses
vous savez qui a annoncé récemment ma
candidature cette personne je l'avais
déjà pressenti mais nous n'avions pas
arrêter notre décision et je
souhaiterais lui donner la primeur de
mon choix pour albert ii d'une commune
d'une grande
elle est originaire d'une commune du
nord de la martinique oui oui plus au
nord que cette baril oui plus au nord
que cette marie vous avez vous avez
presque trouvé mais ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas un jeu de devinettes c'est
simplement une question de correction
je reprends sur quel programme sur le
bilan de l'action s'était m
le bilan est un pli trop tôt pour le
faire on est à une en un an
ce que je constate simplement j'ai tenu
à remettre quelques pendules à l'heure
nous avons au sein de la ctm lancé par
exemple le projet du stade de sainte
marie qui était en panne depuis des
années et que et que d'autres n'avaient
pas pu faire avancer nous arrivons aux
affaires à fred marie-jeanne avec les
conseils des uns et des autres en
particulier évidemment de votre
serviteur décide de lancer ce projet a
visité des gens campagne à nouveau
plaisir c'est à dire vous avez utilisé
votre action en tant que assemblée de
martinique pour déjà mais il y avait un
besoin dans cette zone là il y avait un
besoin pour la jeunesse martiniquaise
sait si nous avions raisonner comme
d'autres monsieur à 0
maire de sainte-marie aurait pu être
entre guillemets aux critères de
l'attitude de d'autres être sanctionné
pour sa trahison
au contraire nous avons voulu servir la
population du nord quand un homme
politique aujourd'hui peut reprocher un
autre d'avoir trahi et entraîné toujours
n'ont trahi parce que je me sens
d'indépendance mourra quelques lignes
vous a fait on va gratter de s'étaler
sur ce registre là mais on travaille pas
ses convictions ont trahis pas ses
convictions on ne peut pas on peut pas
avoir dit et s'est engagé dans une voie
pendant avoir été élu avec le soutien de
claude lise et de et d'alfred marie
jeanne et parce que l'on pense que ils
ne vont pas gagner les élections de la
collectivité territoriale changer de
bord ce n'est pas élégant un mois de la
présidentielle françois fillon que vous
supportez après l'échec de votre pôle à
nicolas sarkozy doit-il se maintenir
malgré ses déboires est-ce que vous
suivrez tout à l'heure ça sa conférence
de presse alors je suivrai la conférence
de presse mais je vais vous dire il y à
il y a plusieurs aspects à ce problème
là il ya un aspect judiciaire
la justice dira le moment venu si
monsieur fillon est condamné ou pas il
ya un aspect moral sur le plan de la
morale mais sous monsieur fillon
monsieur fillon a commis une faute il ya
un aspect politique il doit tirer les
conséquences de cette faute et ne pas
embarrasser son parti son mouvement
politique et donc je pense que monsieur
fillon serait bien inspiré lui demander
de partir j'ajouterai qu'il soit beau
sourire de là je repars dépenses je
pense qu'il doit le faire oui dans
l'intérêt de sa famille politique et et
puis tout simplement parce que le
trouble que sem cette affaire dans
l'opinion publique
vous savez dans un moment là les choses
sont difficiles pour tout le monde
on demande des efforts à tout le monde
c'est un mauvais signal dans votre camp
dans votre cas cette affaire où les gens
nagent dans le jir dans votre famille
politique ou sur l'ensemble de la classe
politique toutes obédiences avant un
effet sur notre famille politique et ça
aura un effet sur l'ensemble de la
classe politique et je crains mais tout
ça faisait s'il ya un an pour nous à
8000 km même pour nous à 8000 km je
dirais surtout pour nous à 8000 km qui
sommes attentifs à ces choses là et qui
sommes dans un dans un département où il
ya beaucoup de gens qui ont de trop
petites retraites
et qui sont évidemment sensible et plus
sensible encore à cela donc moi je peux
pas cautionner cela moralement je peux
pas le cautionner
revenons à la législative
vous étiez dernièrement à saint pierre
vous avez rencontré des démarcheurs qui
aurait pu être à la retraite et qui
continue à travailler parce que
justement le montant de leurs revenus
n'est pas suffisant qu'est-ce que vous
proposeriez là dessus sachant que nous
sommes département amené à être le leur
alors dépouillé vous avez une première
chose qui est kim importantes à dire est
que les martiniquais ne savent pas c'est
que les caisses de retraite à la
martinique sont excédentaires
c'est à dire que les retraites payées
sont inférieures au montant des
cotisations
bon c'est important que ceux et celles
entre eux et essai et c'est entre ces
honteux parce que les retraites sont
souvent ici plus basse que les retraites
versées en moyenne dans l'hexagone est
accusé par diallo plaisir qui serait dû
au mois de juin prochain
qu'est ce qui ferait de là dessus eh
bien écoutez je les ai indiqué dans ma
campagne si vous reprenez le thème de ma
campagne de 2012
je disais tout simplement qu'il n'était
pas acceptable qu'au simple la
république il ya une disparité qui soit
une injustice ici nous avons plus de
chômage nous avons des plus de personnes
âgées et nous avons des retraites plus
basse tout ceci est illogique anormal et
injuste donc forcément les autres
députés qui n'ont rien fait là dessus et
sont à condamner
je ne condamne personne je constate
simplement et je dis simplement que pour
ma part je souhaiterais terre je ne
ferai pas de concessions là dessus je
veux pas raconter aux martiniquais que
je suis le député du nord du sud du
centre et que je vais prévoir de mettre
une crèche ici ou là je vais attaquer
les problèmes de fond qui concerne la
population martiniquaise et qui relève
de la décision de l'assemblée nationale
cette décision sur les retraites est une
décision importante
ce sera évidemment au centre de mes
combats et dans l'intérêt de la
martinique
merci d'avoir été ce matin avec nous il
ya mon plaisir rappelle que vous êtes
candidat à la députation dans la
circonscription du nord de la martinique
merci bonne journée
[Musique]
l'attaqué